i have shared a lot about my marriage in
the past and now real housewives of
potomac star ashley darby is sharing her
marriage has come to an end not a
conventional person and
it's i just don't think it's going to
come as a shock to anybody the 33 year
old reality star confirmed her split
from her husband michael on tuesday
after almost eight years as mr and mrs
michael and i
are an unconventional couple in many
ways and we have
more hurdles to overcome
than in my opinion
other marriages ashley opens up about
their decision to go separate ways on
bravo's website she speculates quote
people will be quick to assume that the
causes were too much intrusion by
reality tv into the most personal parts
of our lives age gap issues cultural
problems or child-rearing differences
michael and i are different ages we're
from different continents i mean like
we're just as different as you could
possibly be and it introduces so many
problems and yes i mean it's just
it is what it is but we definitely have
some hiccups ashley says that while all
that may have affected their pure love
for each other there was no one reason
for their split quote we are now both at
very different stages in our lives and
have different goals for our futures we
both want the other to achieve true
happiness and fulfillment and feel that
we cannot do this together the bravo
star goes on to note that she and the 62
year old real estate mogul are still on
good terms writing that while their
romantic bond is broken they will always
love and respect each other people say
that
becoming parents can really change a
relationship dynamic i
never thought that would be me
but
it was me the former couple shares two
sons one-year-old dylan and two-year-old
dean and now ashley says they are
committed to working together and
putting their hearts and souls into
raising their boys he's my baby daddy so
you know i'm much more conscious about
how we talk because everything that we
do now affects the baby so i make sure
that we have real discussions that
address things right then quote they
will always feel loved and supported for
they were truly created out of love i
mean marriage is just so hard and
it's really hard being a public figure
and having difficulties and it's even
more difficult when you decide to talk
about them and
say some things that aren't necessarily
fitting the mold of what people think a
marriage is or should be back in 2020
ashley opened up to e.t about how
challenging marriage can be and in 2021
she said that while they had decided
they were done expanding their family
after two kids she still held out hope
that they might eventually have a third
baby we just came back from the bahamas
last week
and
you know like
there there's potential that i could you
know be pregnant and it's like you know
we're thinking about like what would
that look like or would that feel like
so even though we said no
it's like the possibility of that is
still a little exciting and i'm like
well if we have that little blame of of
hope maybe we will have at least one
more kid but we do and michael is very
aware that you know he's going to be
he's 62 now so does he necessarily want
to do that and miss out on more
things you know
for later in their lives i don't know so
we're really racing against the clock
but if mother nature has other plans
then you know we'll follow her lead and
while ashley and michael's relationship
was a major storyline on real housewives
we had hit rock bottom
and i was like oh
that's it homeboy i'm out she told et
that they were an unconventional couple
in many ways but had a lot of love for
each other i love my husband he's a
great father he's a great husband
and
my relationship is going to withstand
it's strong enough to withstand a lot
i'm not going to let the media or the
public or the opinions of others affect
what i do and how i approach my marriage
so everyone's going to have an opinion
i'm sure there'll be some very strong
reactions to what they see and what
happens but ultimately the only person
who really lays next to michael at night
and has to have these discussions is me
so
that's that
[Music]